so you said your favorite scene in
interstellar is the intense docking
scene with the AI and Cooper talking
saying uh Cooper what are you doing
docking it's not possible no it's
necessary
such a good line by the way just so many
questions there why an AI
in that scene presumably is supposed to
be
able to compute a lot more than the
human
is saying it's not optimal why the human
I mean that's a movie but shouldn't they
AI know much better than the human
anyway uh what do you think is the value
of setting seemingly impossible goals
so like uh
our initial intuition which seems like
something that uh you have taken on that
Elon espouses
that where the initial intuition of the
community might say this is very
difficult and then you take it on anyway
with a crazy deadline you're just from a
human engineering perspective
um
uh have you seen the value of that
I wouldn't say that setting impossible
goals exactly is is a good idea but I
think setting very ambitious goals is a
good idea I think there's a what I call
sublinear scaling of difficulty which
means that 10x problems are not 10x hard
usually 10x 10x harder problem is like 2
or 3x harder to execute on because if
you want to actually like if you want to
improve the system by 10 it costs some
amount of work and if you wanna 10x
improve the system it doesn't cost you
know 100x amount of work and it's
because you fundamentally change the
approach and it if you start with that
constraint then some approaches are
obviously dumb and not going to work and
it forces you to reevaluate
um and I think it's a very interesting
way of approaching problem solving if it
requires a weird kind of thinking it's
just going back to your like PhD days
it's like how do you think which ideas
in in the machine Learning Community are
solvable yes it's uh it requires what is
that I mean there's the cliche of first
prince suppose thinking but like it
requires to basically ignore what the
community is saying because doesn't the
community doesn't a community in science
usually draw lines of what isn't isn't
possible right and like it's very hard
to break out of that without going crazy
yeah I mean I think a good example here
is you know the Deep learning revolution
in some sense because you could be in
computer vision at that time when during
the Deep learning sort of revolution of
2012 and so on uh you could be improving
a computer vision stack by 10 or we can
just be saying actually all this is
useless and how do I do 10x better
computer vision well it's not probably
by tuning a hog feature detector I need
a different approach
um I need something that is scalable
going back to uh Richard Sutton's
um and understanding sort of like the
philosophy of the uh bitter lesson and
then being like actually I need a much
more scalable system like a neural
network that in principle works and then
having some deep Believers that can
actually execute on that mission make it
work so that's the 10x solution